[Musique]
bonjour à tous la majeure partie de ce
journal tout en image sera consacré aux
résultats des élections régionales un
strutin marqué par une forte poussée de
la gauche le PS devient la première
force politique du pays avec près de 30
% des voix il devance l'UMP 27 % les
veres confirment leur 3e place des
européennes avec 12,5 % mais Europe
Écologie est talonné par le Front
National qui effectue un retour
inattendu le parti de Jean-Marie Le Pen
pourra se maintenir dans plus de la
moitié des régions suivent le Front de
Gauche 6 % et le modem de François
baayerou qui s'effondre avec seulement 4
% le total des voies de gauche atteint
les 50 % près du double de la droite
parlementaire pour qu'il s'agit d'un des
plus mauvais résultats sous la 5e
République la gauche peut espérer
remporter les 22 régions dimanche
prochain tout de suite tout ce qu'il
faut retenir de ce scrutin
un sourire radieux Martine au est
désormais à la tête du premier parti de
France elle est en pass de réussir son
Paris des régions toutes en rose mais
hier soir elle joue la
modeste ce résultat est un encouragement
pour nous lorsque les socialistes sont
unis et tournés vers les Français et
bien ils retrouve leur
confiance triste soirée en revanche à
l'UMP la stratégie d'union premier tour
est un échec mais compte tenu de la très
forte abstention François Fillon tente
de relativiser la défaite la faible
participation ne permet pas de tirer un
enseignement national de ce
scrutin contrairement à tous les
pronostics rien n'est donc joué pour le
second tour dans de nombreuses régions
française les écologistes s'attendaient
à mieux il rêvaient de transformer l'
des européenne et de devancer le PS dans
une ou de région espoir déçu mais il
s'installe comme la troisième force
politique c'est un vrai succès qui nous
oblige tous et toutes qui nous oblige à
travailler ensemble et nous allons
commencer à le faire dès ce soir en
travaillant un rassemblement plus large
de la gauche et des écologistes pour
battre l'UMP dans toutes les régions
c'est la surprise du premier tour la
renaissance du Front national avec près
de 12 % il talonne Europe
du coup il se maintiendra dans les 12
régions où il le peut provoquant ainsi
autant de
triangulaires François Baayou lui savait
que cette élection serait un mauvais
moment à passer mais il ne veut pas
croire à la fin de son parti être
minoritaire c'est une déception c'est un
désagrément c'est un passage rude mais
ce n'est pas une honte à Notter qu'à
l'issue de ce premier tour les jeux sont
faits dans une seule région la
Guadeloupe ou la liste socialiste la
largement
emporté